hi everyone welcome to biology professor
let's start today by asking a question
why should we care about bacterial
growth preferences I think the best
answer to that question is it by
understanding the preferences that
bacteria have in order to be able to
grow we can also learn how to keep them
from growing and how to prevent the
growth of bacteria that we don't want to
grow like the bacteria that will spoil
food and cause food poisoning or other
human pathogens now that's why today
we're talking about bacteria temperature
preferences bacteria can be classified
into five main groups based on what
temperature's they grow at I've got a
graph here let's talk first about what's
on the y-axis here we have the rate of
bacterial growth this means that
bacteria have a minimum temperature at
which they will grow and then as you
enter into their optimal range their
rate the growth rate of growth increases
and then as you start to reach the
maximal end of their temperature range
that rate of growth will decrease on the
x-axis we have temperature I put it here
in terms of degrees Celsius this is
because both in science and research
applications and also in most of the
world including Europe temperature is
usually expressed in terms of degrees
Celsius I know as Americans we're used
to thinking about temperature and
Fahrenheit so let me help orient you by
saying that zero degrees Celsius is the
temperature at which water reaches 100
degrees Celsius is the temperature at
which water boils and 25 degrees Celsius
is ultimately room temperature so now
let's start talking about those five
classes of bacteria the bacteria that
grow the coldest conditions are called
high profile
these are bacteria that can grow in
freezing conditions their optimal
temperature is between zero and ten or
even zero and 15 degrees Celsius and
these are the bacteria that grow in
polar regions and in deep ocean water so
the water that is very very cold next we
have Cybertron's sacra tropes are
bacteria that grow typically in this ten
to twenty degree Celsius range they can
also grow at this range that's a little
bit below 10 degrees Celsius which is
typically refrigeration temperature so
if you've ever had food you put into the
refrigerator and it's spoiled the
bacteria responsible for that is some
type of cyber truck next as we get into
these warmer temperatures
we have Eva files means the files grow
best in the range from 20 to 40 degrees
Celsius these are bacteria where for
examples you have some food and you
leave it sitting out for several hours
and then you get sick from food
poisoning because the food spoiled
because you forgot to put it into the
refrigerator those types of bacteria are
in some files also human body
temperature is about 37 degrees Celsius
which is about where the stash line is
so all human pathogens are also then we
have thermal
either bacteria that prefer warmer
temperatures so we're getting up into
this 50 to 60 degrees Celsius either
optimal growth range and then finally on
the warmest end of the temperature
spectrum we have hyperthermophiles eater
bacteria that can grow even in
temperatures around the boiling
temperature of water they all typically
grow above 60 or 70 degrees Celsius
these are the bacteria that are growing
and hot springs and also in very deep
ocean vents so in oceans you have the
very very cold water where for example
e-sign files are living you also could
have the deep ocean vents that are
basically the openings of underwater
volcanoes this is very very hot you can
imagine just how hot volcanoes and magma
are so hyperthermophiles are the
bacteria that are living in those
conditions so I want to wrap this up by
saying that temperature is obviously a
very big consideration when you're
thinking about what different types of
bacteria need to grow but it's not the
only consideration by any means bacteria
also have different requirements for
example for pH there are many bacteria
that prefer to grow to a new Cole pH
while some prefer acidic or basic
conditions there are also various
nutritional requirements so for example
some bacteria absolutely require oxygen
in order to be able to survive on the
other hand oxygen can be toxic to many
other kinds of bacteria then there's a
whole host of other nutritional
requirements different bacteria will
require different levels of nitrogen or
sulfur carbon dioxide or different trace
metals and these are all things that
have to take into account when you're
studying
the waves of different types of bacteria
grow so that's it for today I hope you
guys learned a lot and thanks for
watching